According to my calculations, at this point, when I'm worried, the
performance is almost even
, and the handling of the job type is greatly influenced by the mental state
.  I'm a devoted guardian support
[music]
Oh, I have to regenerate my legs
Hey, my physical strength is even lower, and it's easy to do.
The world can be saved, but
why am I so frustrated?It's a
heart, and like rock-paper-scissors, Koro-sensei came out one after
another.If
it's true, that's what we wanted to find in this classroom.
Looks like it's over Now, I
wonder if I'll be able to withstand the next rush
It's the first time I've been cornered this far It's a
seemingly naive game It's an old-fashioned assassination It's
really well calculated
I have a lot of things I want to ask you guys, but
first the game  I'm not likely to speak unless I win
9th place in the month
.  Sounds like it's
always
[music] The
same type of work Yes, teacher No. 2 Kubo is the same If
you lose your tentacles, you'll misuse them
The video of the gay model store fee is a little
far away It
's wrapped in the teacher's shell, so there shouldn't
be any damage
But your feet are on the outside of the ring. The
teacher wins.